[Music]
is this the moment of truth when
historians come back to look at
Britain's relationship with Europe is it
now they'll talk about or will they
focus on something else will it be the
leave vote in 2016
David Cameron's Bloomberg speech a few
years earlier well what if the events
were living through were really set in
train when we were looking the other way
when our eyes were glued to the Olympics
and we celebrated the Diamond Jubilee
what if the seminal year the moment our
fate became preordained was 2012 we
didn't notice it at the time but a chain
reaction was happening beneath our feet
causing ripple effects that were still
feeling now this is the story about how
seemingly unconnected events in Europe
Africa the Middle East and most of all
here in Britain have left us where we
are today it is the story about how 2012
was the year everything changed
it might seem an odd yes choose in some
sense this 2012 was the year of Europe's
greatest triumph awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize faded as the world's most advanced
civilized continent and you can
understand why it's the ultimate story
of turning defeat into victory it's
impossible to tell Europe's story
without considering this the aftermath
of the second world war a continent in
ruins and a question how to make
conflict like this a history in 1946
Churchill gave a famous speech where he
called for the creation of the United
States of Europe no longer would the
continent be locked in conflict it would
be locked in political union but ever
since then we've been asking ourselves a
question what about us are we in the
club or out of it
for much of that time the answer was
focused on the economic relationships
steer clear of the politics but every
five years came a new European treaty
adding more EU power increasing
integration creating a closer and closer
Union and when was the next treaty jus
20
twelve but then events intervened the
euro crisis in Spain island and most
obviously Greece was a reminder that the
project had some serious problems Greece
was bailed out but only on terms so
harsh it suffered an unprecedented
depression for many liberal euro files
the Greek crisis was the real turning
points up until then they've been able
to hold up Europe as this defender of
human rights this bastion of liberal
democracy but now all of a sudden it was
imposing economic pain on one of its
most vulnerable members in other words
2012 was the moment Europe lost many of
its most important intellectual
defenders the euro crisis posed another
problem
it caused a dive in Britain's economy up
until 2012 it looked like the UK economy
was gonna recover relatively quickly
there were only another few years of
austerity yet to come then the euro
crisis happened austerity had to be
prolonged the economy suffered living
standards fell and the gap between the
haves in the city and everyone else only
widens something that many people think
contributed to the eventual decision to
leave in 2016
meanwhile in the Middle East the Arab
Spring was timing Agosti 2012 with the
year the Syrian civil war really took
hold and as millions of displaced
refugees from Middle East and North
Africa looked to escape the seeds of
Europe's refugee crisis were planted a
chain reaction of events that landed
with a thump here in Westminster and now
once again all eyes on this place as MPs
decide what the next chapter of
Britain's relationship with the Europe
is the club we can't quite decide
whether we want to be in all out of but
if there's one thing history has taught
us it is that this story is not going to
be over anytime soon anyway the eventual
outcome is likely to be out of the
politicians hands ask David Cameron 2012
was the year he decided privately to
call an in/out referendum the polling
was telling him Britain would definitely
vote remain but beneath his feet the
earth was shifting deeper austerity the
gap between haves and have-nots economic
depression on the continent of refugee
crisis brewing and a nation
rediscovering its pride in its own flag
and its own identity in hindsight it's
so obvious the ingredients were all
there for the lead vote four years later
but we were all too busy looking the
other way Eddie Conway Sky News
[Music]